all right let's talk about how to get
some relief with a sinus infection or
sinusitis especially if it's chronic
it's usually going to be a fungus if
it's chronic
and there could also be something called
biofilms biofilms are
little calcium
houses or igloos
that protect the bacteria or other types
of microbes
from being destroyed by an antibiotic so
there are some things to inhibit the
formation of biofilms as well as kill
the fungus
naturally without the side effects and
i'm going to recommend getting a nasal
irrigation or nasal rinse
you can make your own but it's probably
going to be a lot less expensive just to
buy one with the ingredients in it i
want to mention something about kimchi
juice
i've done another video on this and i
will put the link down below
but there just so happens to be
a very specific microbe
in this fermented
uh korean
uh product which is very effective of
clearing out
mucus and infections in your sinuses and
you could take a little bit of that
juice
dilute it
and with a little q-tip
just each day put some up in your nose
and that can actually repopulate this
microbe and so then you have this normal
balance of the friendly bacteria that
can help prevent the pathogens and the
unfriendly
yeast and fungus that can grow you see
when you take an antibiotic you kill off
the bacteria but you don't kill off the
fungus in your gut this is why the
biggest side effect from an antibiotic
is an overgrowth of a fungus which is
called candida
same thing in the sinuses when you kill
off the bacteria you get this overgrowth
of this fungus
okay the two
main ingredients that i would recommend
in a nasal rinse and you can get these
online there's many different kinds you
can probably get one at the drugstore
but the point is that these are the two
ingredients that i'm going to recommend
in this nasal rinse which isn't a saline
solution okay
so number one xylitol
this is one of my favorite sugars it's a
sugar alcohol actually so it's very low
on the glycemic index
i usually have this in my one cup of
coffee a day i have a small cup but
xylitol
tastes
pretty close to sugar but it doesn't
have the spike of blood sugars but it
has some other properties it can
decrease the formation of biofilms so
it's also good if you're going to get it
in a gum and chew it because it can
actually reduce the bathrooms in your
mouth which then
inhibits the formation of plaquing and
tartar and things like that in your
mouth
but xylitol also suppresses the growth
of fungus okay so xylitol would be a
really good ingredient in this nasal
rinse and then grapefruit seed extract
quite amazing it's a very powerful
anti-fungal very powerful antibacterial
it's as effective as 30 pharmaceutical
antibiotics and 18 fungicides
with slightly less
side effects and i'm being very
sarcastic because i don't think it has
any side effects
but the combination of these two would
be a great remedy in a nasal rinse to
use if you have this chronic sinus
infection or this mucus or stuffy nose
that you have year-round
now baby shampoo
this has been
studied and what they've done is they've
taken one percent of this baby shampoo
in a saline solution so you're not
taking much you're just taking a little
drop in some salt water
and you can put this in the nasal rinse
as well
and this also can inhibit biofilms in
other words you have some options you
could actually just
buy one of these nasal rinse empty
bottles get some saline solution and put
a a drop of this in there if you wanted
and start to irrigate your sinuses
anyway i just wanted to give you a good
remedy if you have a sinus issue and you
want something pretty effective all
right thanks for watching
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i'd really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others